what's going on guys welcome back to
geek culture explained my name is rob
and in this video i'm going to be
telling you guys how it is that i know
why it is the eternals walked away from
involving themselves in the affairs of
humanity
one of the things that i love about this
youtube channel is reading your all's
comments you guys may not believe that i
read your comments because i guess maybe
a lot of youtubers don't but i do and
one of the things you guys always tell
me is hey rob i thought of this
i thought of that and while this isn't
necessarily based on any particular
theory that i saw in the comments it is
based on some comments you guys left
which is that idea of the celestials
seems overly complicated now for those
of you guys who don't know what i'm
talking about the idea that we had in
the previous videos is that the eternals
basically walked away from involving
themselves with humanity
because they were told not to by the
celestials and while that may very well
be a possibility because that's what
happened in the comics you guys did make
a good point when you said that seems a
little
over complicated for the marvel
cinematic universe and that got me
thinking
what's the number one rule of the mcu
well the number one rule of the mcu is
basically the same rule as occam's razor
all things being equal the simplest
explanation tends to be the right one
and so having said that what's the
simplest explanation for why it is the
eternals would have walked away from
involving themselves in the affairs of
mortal men
and instead would have simply just sat
back and watched everything unfold the
simplest answer
is because they chose to so let's say
the eternals were basically the reason
why humanity achieved technology in the
first place which given what we saw in
the trailer
they basically are we saw humanity in a
very primitive form they probably had
not invented the wheel if they had they
had probably just now done it so the
question is if humanity is exceedingly
basic at that point in time
the eternals show up with this advanced
technology and basically gift humanity
technology and humanity uses that
technology to progress to its current
form then we could probably look at the
eternals and say that they love humanity
in the same capacity
that a parent loves a child this is
evidenced by all the myriad of scenes
that we see over the course of the
trailer one of the eternals getting
their hair brushed by one of the kids
the looks on their faces in terms of
happiness
and pride and watching humanity grow and
progress given the gift of technology
given to them
by the eternals so why would they leave
let's go to marvel comics for a second
so in marvel comics there's a group
called the watchers and you guys have
likely heard of them the entire policy
of the watchers is non-intervention they
basically just watch the universe unfold
and chronicle everything that happens
but it always wasn't that way originally
the watchers were one of the oldest
races in the universe the only race that
we know of that might be older than the
watchers would be the races that the
elders of the universe come from the
grand master who you guys saw in thor
ragnarok the collector by benitro del
toro who's been in a whole host of
marvel cinematic universe movies we
don't really know much about their races
we just know they're the last surviving
members of their races and that's really
all we get but back to the watchers
the important thing is that in the early
days the watchers decided that because
they were so technologically advanced
they wanted to share their technology
with the universe so they went to a
planet they provided the technology to
that primitive race on that planet and
the result of this is that that race had
a kind of golden age where they used
that technology to advance themselves
the watchers looked upon them with pride
until that race started splitting up
among religious and political lines this
ultimately led to a civil war and in the
end the technology that was provided to
that race by the watchers was used by
that race to essentially destroy
themselves the watchers were ultimately
just crushed and disheartened and the
results of this is they
walked away they stood hands off of the
universe and just chronicled everything
as it unfolded now let's take that
concept and let's apply it to the
eternals
looking at the comments that you guys
were giving me one of the things you
guys pointed out with that giant huge
landmass is that that's most likely
mesopotamia
and the giant city that we see
constructed at the end of the trailer
it's most likely babylon a lot of you
guys pointed to the idea of it being the
ishtar gates as the reason why now here
in the real world babylon was ultimately
conquered by cyrus and the persians but
let's assume
that didn't happen in the marvel
cinematic universe let's assume that
instead
the technology gifted to humanity by the
eternals ultimately led humanity to
splitting among these political and
religious lines and that group
self-destructed in turn the eternals
would look at that and say
no more and they were ultimately hands
off which really seems to indicate why
it is that the eternals are exceedingly
happy and proud when you see them
looking at the early days of humanity
when they're building baby cute cities
and using the technology the eternals
gave them
and then you see the eternals later on
and they look a little sad with regards
to where humanity is at the moment now i
know what you guys are gonna say
rob the watchers already exist in the
marvel cinematic universe we saw them
they were hanging out with stan lee
that's true but just because the
watchers exist does not mean their
origin is the same
case in point carol danvers captain
marvel in the comics she became captain
marvel because she basically stumbled
across what was more or less a wishing
machine and then wished to have the same
powers as captain marvel and her wish
was granted she went forward as miss
marvel and then eventually became
captain marvel during kelly's
pseudocon's run so with all that being
said the question we now have to answer
is why the eternals just now coming back
if they watched and guided humanity and
then basically went hands off because
the people in babylon went nuts and
destroyed themselves why now
i think the answer to this question lies
in infinity war in avengers in-game
let's take a look at the motives of the
eternals for a second if they saw what
humanity did in the city of babylon and
they said we can't give them technology
anymore because they'll use it to
destroy themselves and they likely
dispersed and went about the world and
did their own thing now you could make
an argument that over the course of
human history we've achieved great
things i think you could also point out
that while humanity has done some great
things over the course of our history
we've done more things that are actually
worse would it really be that hard to
believe the eternals just kind of
watched humanity as it unfolded and just
saw us becoming
increasingly more violent all the
different wars and things like that that
exist it's no wonder they chose not to
intervene anymore because if humanity
has proven anything to the eternals over
the course of our history following our
first encounter with them it's that they
were correct and assuming that humanity
was just inherently self-destructive but
all this came to a head
with the events of avengers in-game see
the funny thing about avengers in-game
is that if you look at it for what it is
humanity for a brief moment in time had
the most powerful artifact in the
entirety of the universe with the
infinity gauntlet at their disposal the
avengers could have basically done
anything they wanted to they could have
rewritten the entire history of the
universe but they could have made
themselves gone captain america and the
avengers could have handed it over to
the federal government and the
government could have weaponized it just
like they wanted to do with the iron man
suit nia man 2 or the government could
have just taken it any number of things
could have happened instead the avengers
brought back everybody who was dusted
and then captain america took the
infinity stones and took them back to
their own individual locations now
assuming the eternals didn't really
understand the planning that was going
on and assuming they didn't overhear the
conversation between the ancient one and
the incredible hulk then they had no
knowledge of the fact that this was done
because it would disrupt the timeline
maybe they would have figured it out on
his
own who knows but the important thing
here is that if the events of avengers
in game did any one particular thing for
the eternals it's proof
that even though humanity had in his
possession an incredible weapon that it
could have used
to obliterate all existence or certainly
wipe out anybody they consider to be
opposition
instead they did the right thing and so
that basically verified the fact that
humanity is actually capable of
incredible things i think the other
reason why the eternals are coming back
is because when you had different
conflicts on earth it was one thing when
it was humanity fighting humanity it's
different when you have an eternal
that's gone awry that shows up on earth
and then decides to just
pop off and go nuts the other
possibility here actually lies in the
current eternals comics coming out from
marvel comics and one of the things they
define thanos as is being what's called
the sin of titan basically the eternal
who went awry the reason why this
matters is because he is inherently of
eternal genealogy and the fact that
humanity had developed superheroes and
the fact that these superheroes were
powerful enough to not only topple an
eternal but then to also do the right
thing with all the power they possess
basically show the eternals that
humanity was more or less ready for them
to arrive
beyond that i have no clue why the
eternals have returned i'm curious what
you all's comments are let me know down
below and i will catch you all later
peace